it is friday and season two is out lots
to talk about for sure with you so
listen season one you became a star
overnight which was incredible how would
you say that your life changed after
season one premiered
i went from a lawyer in texas to
suddenly someone who couldn't cross the
street without someone yelling their
name um it's been interesting i travel a
lot i go around the world and i've seen
the same like in paris and athens and
obviously when i visited india so i have
to say my anonymity is definitely gone
and the best and most rewarding part is
all the people i get to meet and the
conversations i'm having about the
topics that indian matchmaking brought
up in our community about castism and
colorism and sexism which is you know a
big part of my storyline and um i think
that that for me has been the ultimate
reward i moved to new york i got a new
job which is
writing and uh writing a book and the
book is a bestseller in india today i
could never have imagined this two years
ago so it's been quite a wild ride yeah
it has been a wild ride and always along
with all the love that you receive there
is always
those haters
there's always got to be those haters um
but you did receive a lot of online
bullying after season one and during
season one which i can only assume was
difficult to go through but in the end
where you are now
would you say that
that almost made you even a stronger
person within yourself
yeah i actually acknowledge those people
in my book and i say thank you for
giving me a voice like standing up to
that vitriol and that cyber bullying
even the death threats which by the way
very scary but standing up to that and
saying like i'm gonna reclaim my
narrative i'm gonna tell my story
despite you um it's a very powerful
moment and i think um for me it
definitely changed you know the the
journey of my life
yeah
you know during season one let's call a
spade a spade there was lots of tension
between you and seema that was very
apparent um
is there a relationship now between the
two of you have you spoken since season
two has come out where do you two stand
right now
um i i don't know if the viewers see
this but on season two i choose not to
work with sema and i'm one of the since
that takes an alternate route of
matchmaking which i thought was really
valuable i think so much about south
asian communities is the community and
matchmaking is a big part of that and so
you'll see in my story in season two
that i go forth and i allow one of my
friends from the netflix family from
dating ground gurkey to set me up with
her cousin and i in the past year or two
have given up on formal matchmaking um
and i've used my community my friends my
ex-co-workers uh the journalists that i
speak to have set me up with men i think
it's it's a big part of matchmaking and
i'm glad i got to show that
uh how do you think
that relationship could ever be rebuilt
or is it just kind of over you are each
living your separate lives because
listen clearly you both had very
different values of and ideas of what a
relationship is yes
very different values and i always say
that your matchmaker has to be on your
team she has to be your cheerleader if
she or he and they have to listen to you
actively listen to you and when i felt i
personally wasn't getting that i knew
that the relationship would would have
to be over i mean we broke up and and
that's absolutely fine i wish everybody
well i want everyone's careers to thrive
but i do think that in matchmaking you
have to find someone who's
aligned with you and for me sema
personally just wasn't aligned with me
yeah definitely now coming back for
season two two-part question here
number one was it an easy decision and
number two was you returning kind of
dependent on being able to go forward
in finding or hoping to find love on
your own without the help of sema
telling my story both seasons is about
authenticity for me and i don't want to
ever
put a story out there that doesn't
reflect me and my values and so for me
um i was very clear about that i think
the viewers see that um and it was it
was the only way i was ever going to
tell my story so yeah yeah
doing it my way telling it my way that
was definitely my decision and that was
the only way i was ever going to do it
again
you know it's
really difficult to sometimes get so
open raw and personal because you know
millions of people around the world are
watching you and following you and
listening to the things that you have to
say what have other women uh in specific
come up to you and said about watching
your journey on the show
women have had an outpouring of love for
me and to say that i'm humbled by it is
an understatement they are just so kind
and so um inspired they say by seeing my
representation on television and they
they call me confident and um a woman
who knows how to set boundaries they
aspire to do the same but i have to say
that the fans the viewers that inspire
me the most are the the girl dads i
actually posted to my social media
recently this long text from this father
of two 15 year old girls who are half
south asian themselves and he said i
love that they see you on television i
love that and they have a book that they
can they can hold and talk to me about
he's like we all bought our own copies
about three copies we're not sharing can
you imagine this dad this dad of two
teenagers um wants his daughters to
reflect me and wanted to read my story
alongside them they have a book club in
their family i was like i was literally
bawling i was like can i share this on
my social media you made this experience
right here all worth it
that is incredible and that's the power
of being a writer and being honest and
vulnerable and open and that's what
you're doing yeah
you are still looking for love we're not
going to spoil anything but you are
still looking for love uh you know this
is et canada maybe your partner is
living in canada somewhere who knows so
i want to know
three words
what three words are you looking for in
a future partner
that's tough um kind
communicative
and
inquisitive
those are great three words thank you i
just came up with them oh it's awesome
because most people would be like funny
cute but no that's right inquisitive is
yeah that's great i mean if a partner
from indian matchmaking said those words
you would know you would know she was
struggling
uh how do you hope to inspire people by
once again
appearing on indian matchmaking and do
you think people will continue to
connect with your story
um i've already in the past you know
week heard from so many people who have
connected with it so many women of color
have expressed to me that setting
boundaries is really hard for them and
so for me to go on the show and say i'll
continue to share my stories but on my
terms as uncomfortable as that may be
for me at times and that's been a really
powerful statement for them and a really
powerful illustration for them and so i
just think that that has been incredible
to watch and see um happen over the past
you know week already and who knows
what's to come who knows what's to come
maybe season three who knows
i can't say either way who knows you
know the final question i want to ask
you and i think it's an important one
because it's difficult to find a partner
i consider myself lucky i've been in a
relationship with my partner for
almost 15 years now which is insane to
me
but do you still believe in love do you
believe that there is somebody out there
for you
yeah 100
there is not a doubt in my mind and i
know that i'm going to meet them very
soon um i say this
very often i'm so happy right now i'm
happy building a life that i love and i
think that that has created even more
space for the perfect partner to come
walking through the door so um i'm here
and i'm ready and uh let's see what you
know the next
few months or the next year um has in
store for me
well we love you we love seeing your
story and we want you to find love
congratulations on the book as well you
are doing amazing things and you know
having that representation out there
from somebody like yourself is
incredibly important for so many people
so thank you for that it was a blast
chatting and uh hopefully season three
always
thank you so much thank you